well I'm Charles poor a manager of
discreet competition I am research on
that we talking about do you do your
base in geometry computations they talk
with essentially what you have been
doing for the last release version 12
all the Bluefish are coming from the
upcoming release
well I'm Transpo working with EDC
computation and I'm going to talk about
the advanced in geometry well
essentially what we have been doing for
the last what we did for based on 12 and
what we have been working since version
12 for the next release later on and
meetly I will focus more to give you
kind of an idea where we are going the
direction as well as you know 20 to
answer several of question you know
several of you have been asking during
the conference and how we hope you know
to improve graph so geometry not
geometry okay
well the key idea in general is that we
build constructor we have operations on
those constructor and we have solver
since the release of geometries
essentially what we do constructor is
like a disk operation is area on the
disk solver is for example you take the
disk you put it in integrate you get the
result so that's roughly the general
idea how we build the whole frame of a
graph and we integrate it into the
system so in version 12 for essentially
we did is that we enhanced the set of
constructor well you didn't want refers
a body solver so we are here the
constructor we added more operation
currently the solver are in the same
state as before but we hope to you know
add support for the new constructor to
those solvers so what I mean is for
example if we add a new constructor like
polyhedra we actually need to support it
in integrate or in solve or in anything
written search right the simple
optimization of visualizations and the
first release actually of geometry we
try to propagate
you know those contrato or you know in
the whole system right so if you take
image we use geometry there you take
visualization we use geometry you do
some Bolly computation you can actually
use a region because we believe that you
know region is kind of one of those
first class it is an object you need to
you know which is essentially in the
language when you want to express things
we actually live in 3d right so
if you want to describe something
usually you have to actually represent
your geometry so we focus on constructor
operation and usability so it's kind of
one point where we want to improve the
usability of the system you know make
stuffs work smoothly you don't have to
convert something to a magistrate John
and such so we try to improve that
usability so that you know you just work
so one first thing we introduces which
is a constructor based as well as is in
that direction which is ability is the
read John Harper right so one thing is
that we trade John Harper
well the region Harper especially auto
visualized anything you have so it's
kind of a representation of a geometric
object and dependent on the underlying
structure right so if you take a mesh
you put it in regional you to visualize
it doesn't really think about the cell
description behind the mesh structure
the same has a disco anything else so
that's kind of roughly the idea so if
you think about it you really that
subset of RN idea you don't look at the
description behind the scene and that
object of your scene you can take it
compute the surface area or you can look
at it as a you know just an visual
object you can apply plot in you know we
have really nice plot team and then you
can get you know nice look of those so
what we think about region is that
region is that key object you can just
wrap you know regenerate a wedge on you
wrap it at home you know you use region
you wrap it around you get something
visual and then you can still continue
to do computation with that and later on
our status explain the distinction
between that and mesh region because
there will be you know a key difference
for well is that even wait later so
essentially when you have a mesh to
enjoy decide to do boolean operation for
example you do difference of two mesh
region right so a difference is an open
you know when you remove an object for
another one you end up with an open set
right but when you manipulate mesh you
want to you know you know getting any
mesh so mathematically
correct right so in mass will preserve
that property people want so we return
you a mesh so that means we add that
additional object essentially we take
the closure or the set but result will
not do that
so region is purely that you know set
point in array so if you apply the same
replication with region you will get a
formal expression which represents you
that open set since when you start to
see that distinction so we kind of
provide provided both both world by the
pure mathematical one as well as the one
of modeling of manipulation of mesh so
that's roughly idea why we have region
and the Constructors well we added two
additional constructor for mesh so we
added the fact I'll set you know counter
set and such as well as the different
speech feeding curves so you can you
know just type them use them in
dimension two or three and what also we
did is essentially we improve the
discretization and that's you know a
continuous work in that side so you can
take an object like that and discretize
it I think this is just a plot range we
need to fix and actually get the object
undo computation on it or convert it has
a region which by the way in the latest
release you can take a message on and
those feed it inside graphics it works
virtually like a primitive graphic
primitive so it's more for convenience
right when you know we don't want you to
apply shown it and change it so it's
that whole idea of usability we try to
make stuff just work okay
well one of the key component in the
whole geometry boolean operation so we
are consciously working on it we know we
do our best to improve it every time
right so boolean operation in any
dimension but currently we focus
essentially in dimension two and three
so here we kind of show you have with
the new primitive you can't do it
centrally Union and as you see here I'm
using the wrapper region just to
automatically visualize it in case where
it come back on evaluated there we have
a nice slice of your object and behind
the scene we are often USBs between to
do that so under you the object of a
kind of a volumetric object and here you
have the difference as I told you before
it has a mesh region
in this case it was a polyhedron so we
assume that they're close so that's why
you actually have that piece but if it's
you know you're purely do mathematics
you should normally don't have that set
on that boundary and the same for region
difference so you have actually the
whole inside then object is closed so in
this case you actually apply opacity
which is kind of you can actually use
wrapper inside wage on to actually
manipulate the object so it's kind of
all that usability we try to provide so
you can just you know easily manipulate
things similar to what you have in
graphics but you are still playing with
the geometry web several of you have
already seen this we showed you in the
last conference we improve in I mean we
provided in a mesh assistant so you have
actually an additional cell there below
where you can actually just click on it
and you have the view of property of
your mesh you can also modified it here
we have the list of the plot teams let
me take a sample one that one so two
magically we change it in place so it
kind of allow you to easily just take
your mesh and I will say roughly edited
so you apply all the basic operation we
have so that you have to plot him there
you have the
Hasan's are you have the different
viewpoint to actually change for your
object and we hope in the future we know
to add more police on there so it kind
of more convenient for manipulations and
the last thing I'll probably talk about
coming from version 12 actually will add
a little bit more but coming from verses
12 in terminal usability is the summary
box for polygons so usually before we
wait no Anthony polygons you evaluate
give you don't evaluated form of
polygons so in the new form we have a
summary box which you have a polygon a
liturgy of the polygon and if you open
it we actually compute some property
it's kind of a deal evaluation we tell
you is a polygon with holes these are
the bounding box and probably the area
and it's actually quite convenient
because like in this case I generate you
know just six polygons actually should
be sixteen so you see that it types it
nicely you can actually play nicely with
it compared to just returning a set of
on evaluate expression right this part
of that usability we try to make the
whole system more convenient more nice
and smooth you mean you want the input
form you want then you copy it and then
we do end performers oh yes it's still a
graphics it is still a graphic community
yep so if I just draw graphics of that
polygon not it change it's just that to
the typeset change to make it more
convenient more nice so you can still
just copy and pastes manipulate has a
normal expression in the system
okay so that kind of make the whole
thing quite usable especially that in 12
we actually enhance polygons added
support of polygons with holes and a lot
of operation so for example we have
polygon decomposition well you can take
a polygon decompose it in convex sample
and such right in those case you can get
you know twenty thousand polygons after
a decomposition so you want it to
typeset nicely in your notebook so
that's why we did all that change okay
but let's lightly look at polygons with
holes so this case is just a nice
example of South Africa and Lesotho
right before to actually do this you
have to use the graphic complex filter
of what and they find that and have it
filled so now we can just use polygons
and define an outer boundary and inner
boundary so our key idea is that any
polygons have a outer boundary and the
set of inner boundaries right so when
you describe a polygon we try to take it
we canonicalize it to that form right
even if is not and we do the operation
as you can imagine even if the polygons
have a holes right if you want to
compute the area if you have the outer
boundary and inner boundary you compute
you know the area of the whole polygon
and then subtract the area of the inner
part so that's actually even efficient
in terms of computations so that's
hopefully polygon with holes so I will
not dig too much in that so we also
added a set of constructor because that
Charlie
I will not say that the definition of
polygon is ambiguous but there is a lot
of definition of polygon specially when
d intersect I mean when there is no self
intersection of the boundary electron in
the mr. clay when you have a polygon you
describe it with the boundary
essentially so when there is no
intersection well everything is fine
everybody assume that your polygon is
described by a set inside the boundary
but when the self intersection is
thought to be ambiguous right so there
are several definition or several
interpretations right so like in our
case since we have
polygons I don't remember when I mean
since - you know mathematical we use
great racing essentially where we define
our polygon so you pick a point to
define your way and then you look at the
number of intersection with a boundary
if it's odd or even you define one your
pulley you know when your point is
inside the polygon or not so that's one
definition and there are several other
ones so what we introduced in the system
is causing polygons and wanting polygons
to give you all those possibility to you
know pick whatever definition you want
based on the 1d number closing count on
the boundary and such so that's the key
idea of having those constructors in the
system and that kind of roughly give us
I mean in any system whatever you bring
it on whatever the polygons they have
you can't just bring it in mathematical
and just apply one of those yes
now so when you import in STL file by
therefore we generate a mesh object
because they're the polygons I define
are usually in with an STL file you
always assume that is a polygon soup we
describe your object so there there is
no ambiguity but usually the 3d object
you have a set of things inside is for
the intersections all you mean the
importer oh why oh okay so that's it
so for import we have essentially a set
of property to a tree between you pick
all right we have bonded image nitrogen
and regions so if you oxidize region
will return you a message on object if
you add your oxygen which returned you
image region object with the region
wrapper around it as a pointer at the
beginning is also will effect later on
the type of operation you are doing
right so if you are doing a region
difference on the mesh region we will
return you a message on but but if you
are doing a region difference on the
region object that's completely
different because you assume that we
preserve that fact that mathematically
you don't have that you know additional
boundary which is or move during the
difference so we provide those different
attribute just to give you the
possibility to build your object what
you want okay so these are the kind of
the base constructor which allows to
essentially cover all possible
definition of polygons and you get
everything the other constructor we
added is a polyhedron so you can
generate a polyhedron I was usual spiky
and use it has a graphic object or a
[Music]
geometric object and you can compute the
volume on all the standard operation on
it
and also what we did is that we are
added you know the basic standard
platonic solid sorta tried on cube cube
octahedron took it Edwyn and icosahedron
she can't just manipulate them directly
on they just work right and has
appointed before if you do an input form
of also the polyhedron essentially it
have that graphic complex like syntax
where you have the list of coordinate
there and then the list of indices and
generally you know we have that form of
you know whose outer inner described
outer boundary and the inner boundary
and that's kind of a canonical form for
a lot of polygons okay so that was kind
of what we have in 12 and if you have
twelve you probably already have all
that so let talk about what's coming in
the next feature of version 12 one so
one of the first thing we did is what to
provide you more geometry and enhance
what you already have
so we are proving the important export
you know beta is faster better support
of you know texture normals and
everything so kind of be
state-of-the-art on that side so HCl
will be much better faster as such but
also what we are adding is you know
additional way to actually be able to
bring geometry to the system without
actually doing the modeling and cost
hurting so one of the common function
will be web Dermott research so
essentially we can type a string similar
to web or just search and we try to kind
of get you the geometry in this case we
are returning a resource object and if
you do a research date on it you
actually get the geometry and in this
case I believe it's using our resource
repository for that word from the
Turkish repository in this case but we
have you know what I stand our sauce why
we can you know get those actually let
me just show an example I can actually
just do a cow hopefully my internet is
working so you'll go behind use
different resources and gives you a set
of choices so in this case we generate a
gallery like rental fees kind of a
gallery picker you can actually look at
it on simmer while I want this cow you
copied you paste and you do a resource
data and essentially then we go and try
to actually imported geometry whatever
file format it is convert it and return
it in the system
so probably the download is taking some
time there so well Wow
there you go so you have the object
there and you can also use the tool and
actually see additional information
about it since that what actually
million of edge you know more than a
million of faces or such and our graphic
actually handle it correctly so that's
kind of one way to actually get geometry
if you want to play with it
okay so I will not talk about this this
is magical activity graph think the
previous speaker done already presented
it but Akira just well you know to give
bridge to different area right we
already build a bridge you can use Red
John image to go and get an image you
take a car so a wedge one you convert it
to an image that's one way or you can
use image mesh to come back and this is
another way where you can actually take
you know image generate the topology in
graph and apply operation on there and
well we don't have the white you know
the stop back but it kind of distal oh
you to you know do all the nice
connectivity analysis on topological
analysis on your mesh so you are not
really presented it earlier so I will
pass on that the other thing we have we
added is essentially topological sauce
which is similar to the connectivity
right so if you have like in this case
environment which Vern ramesh which is a
standard question people have been
asking you know how can you find
adjacent cell which is also kind of
similar to the mesh connectivity so we
introduced adjacent cell I just said
mesh cell function and in this case I
take this cell which is 2 1 as a
highlight in red and you can ask all the
cell of dimension 2 which are adjacent
to that one and so you can do that for
any dimension 0 1 2 3 and they all work
on mesh right and they will also work on
polygon and polyhedron as I told you
earlier in terms of usability we make
sure that you know all of those work
naturally so for those linear primitive
point line polygons and pulley drawn we
look at them has those fundamental cell
on your mesh object so it's kind of
canonical and then everything just work
instead of adding more additional
function for those ok
so related to the topological search we
also added the function nearest cell
which is more geometric search so in
this case if I still have ivana in mesh
and I want to find the nearest cell to
it I can just put it there with the knee
right master and it will give you the
indices of those two cells I can
actually highlight it so and in this
case is a more interesting example where
you can hopefully it actually work my
notebook style is different well in
principle is supposed to actually
highlight and show you the nearest cell
has you moved the ball when the
highlighting is changed completely
okay well with the short term I have I
just want to point out two main
direction we have been going with
geometry so in this release we are
supporting geo grid position
so essentially you can look at it as
during geometry on the pond'rous chart
projected object on the card so Hoffa
speaking is cartography so we can do
operation on them so in this case you
can take the polygon of the United State
so you get a polygon of Geo grid
position and you can actually do
computation on it can compute the area
or you can actually find the centroid
they will return the Geo grid position
object and you can actually do the
invest and go back and get that charge
your position so this is if you think
about its kind of the projected 3d
object on this you know on each are
twenty card so we also extended to the
same you can actually do the operation
on the globe on the loose ellipsoid
reference we will have for Geographic
objects so in this case a computer I
find the polygon of the US and now I
have a job position so there is no
projection apply in this case you can
compute the area which is actually quite
similar close to the your area you can
also do the computation on on that same
object so sandwich sort so we actually
do that on that reference system and
that work with geo position your
position X Y Z and your position in you
okay well thank you
I will just invite you to go to our next
talk will be a version number to me and
we have danced on the low-level
demo for a on VR thank you
you